Hi everyone. My name is Zillah Mupanda from
Zimbabwe. I'm a global change maker from the
British council initiative. My views on stating
the benefits for the world cup in Africa is
that because I'm a Zimbabwean. I think that
the benefits are temporary because the borders
have been open to Zimbabweans without further
notice really. So that means that Zimbabweans
are free to come into South Africa and work.
But the question is how long will that be
sustainable because the second world cup starts
and Zimbabweans will have to come back. And
obviously the situation still remains the
same at home. So the benefits although are
to a great extent right now, in the future
they are going to be non existent and Africa
will still be in a position of suffering.
For the moment I think that we've put ourselves
in a position as Africa to prove that we're
capable of hosting something this big. So
I actually am really proud of South Africa
and actually Africa as a whole for doing this.
So I'm behind it full force. But just concerned
with the outcome of it. But yeah.